مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم اعرب وزير
الخارجيه البحريني خالد بن احمد ال خليفه
عن تفهم بلاده لموقف السعوديه اعتبارا
الاخوان المسلمين جماعه ارهابيه لكنه اشار
الى ان هذه الجماعه في البحرين ملتزمه
بقانون الدوله ولم يرتكب افرادها ما يضر
بالمصلحه الوطنيه نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش اذا في
محورين هل تعكس تصريحات الوزير البحريني
تباينا في المواقف الخليجيه ازاء الاخوان
المسلمين ثم كيف يمكن دول الخليج العربيه
صياغه مواقف مشتركه ازاء اي تهديد لامنها
مع الحفاظ على مصالحها
[موسيقى]
الوطنيه دعا اذا وزير الخارجيه البحريني
خالد بن احمد ال خليفه دع للنظر الى قضيه
الاخوان المسلمين في كل دوله على حده وليس
باعتبارها قضيه حركه عالم
واشار الوزير في تصريحاته في هذا الشان
الى ان السعوديه تعاملت مع الاخوان بناء
على احداث وقعت على اراضيها وشكلت تهديدا
لها من جانب الاخوان واوضح الوزير
البحريني ان على كل بلد ان يتعامل مع
افراد الاخوان حسب ما يبدر منهم مع ضمان
موقف خليجي موحد
تجاههم
اللقاء لا يعني الالتقاء وذلك لا يعني
التطابق بين اخلص الحلفاء في واحد من
الملفات التي تعصف بالعلاقات بين دول
المنطقه الرياض حضرت حركه الاخوان
المسلمين وتقدمت خطوه اكبر باعتبارها
ارهابيه يجرم من ينتمي اليها والمنامه
تفهمت خطوه الشقيقه الكبرى لكنها تحفظت
فهذا شان على ما قال وزير خارجيتها ليس
عابرا للحدود بل انه مقيد بها لكل دوله ان
تنظر الى اخوانها بطريقتها ووفقا
لمصلحتها نتفهم موقف السعوديه اعتبار
الاخوان المسلمين جماعه ارهابيه لكن يجب
النظر الى قضيه الاخوان في كل دوله على
حده يجب عدم التعامل معها على انها قضيه
حركه عالميه بل باعتبار انه في كل دوله
توجد مجموعه تتصرف بطريقه
معينه هواجس البحرين مختلفه فما يعتبر
تهديدا في دول الجوار قد يكون ضروره
للنظام هناك ما تسميه المنامه تدخلا
ايرانيا وفي الداخل ثمت من يستقوي بالخارج
والحال هذه فان الاخوان ليسوا اعداء على
الاقل ان لم يكونوا حلفاء في ظل تركيبه
ديموغرافيه تميل لصالح مكون على اخر
الرياض رات الامر على نحو مختلف استقبل
العاهل السعودي رئيس مصر المنتخب محمد
مرسي في زياره كانت هي الاولى رجل بعد
انتخابه وبدا كان الرجل يريد ان يطمئن
العمق الخليجي بان بلاده بل حتى جماعته لا
تشكل خطرا على الاستقرار هناك لكن ذلك
سرعان ما تبدد فور الاطاحه بالرجل على يد
وزير دفاعه عبد الفتاح السيسي ان ذاك
صارعت الرياض لتقديم الدعم السياسي واكثر
منه سخاء كان الدعم
المالي في خلفيه الصوره ثمه ما اعتبرها
البعض مخاوف مضخمه ازاء الاخوان فالقاع هي
من دخلت في حاله اداء مع الرياض للاخوان
فجرت وشنت حمله ايديولوجيه شعوا على
حكامها وهو ما رفضته ادبيات الاخوان فلم
جرتهم الرياض وهم في الكويت جزء من نظامها
ودعامه للاستقرار في جوارها البحريني تلك
اسئله تقول السعوديه ان جوابها يتعلق
بالامن الوطني وبالاستقلال الخليجي وهذان
لا تهون
فيهما اذا هذا موضوع حلقتنا و ناقشه الان
مع الكتور عبيد الوسمي استاذ القانون
بجامعه الكويت وعضو البرلمان السابق و في
الاستوديو معنا الاستاذ عبد الله بن حمد
العذبه مدير تحرير صحيفه العرب القطريه
وينضم الينا عبر الهاتف الاستاذ عبد
الرحمن جمشير عضو مجلس الشورى البحريني من
المنامه وينضم الينا من دبي عبر الهاتف
ايضا
الاستاذ علوم العلوم السياسيه الدكتور عبد
الخالق عبد الله نرحب بضيوفنا جميعا في
هذه الحلقه و لنبدا من المنام مع الاستاذ
عبد الرحمن
جمشير استاذ عبد الرحمن جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين جماعه ملتزمه بالقانون في
البحرين لم يرتكب اعضائها شيئا ضد الدوله
يجب النظر الى قضيه الاخوان في كل دوله
على حده هذا الكلام طبعا لوزير
الخارجيه
البحريني جاءت صحيفه الوسط نقلت تصريحا
اخر لنفس الوزير يقول ان البحرين تقف مع
السعوديه والامارات في تصديها لمخططات
الاخوان سيد جمشير كيف نفهم هذا التناقض
في تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
البحريني ليس هناك تناقض انا اعتقد ان
تصريح الوزير الاولي هو تصريح يعني موجه
الى الشان الداخلي البحريني
حركه
الاخوان المسلمين في البحرين ممثلهم في
المنبر الاسلامي حركه وطنيه شاركوا في
المشروع الاصلاحي
وشاركوا في الانتخابات ولهم ممثلين في
البرلمان البحريني وهم في ازمه البحرين
الاخيره وقفوا موقف مشرف من من الازمه ومن
تاكيد عروبه البحرين
و نهجها الاصلاحي وبنفس الوقت يعني تماسك
نسيجها الاجتماعي التصريح الثاني هو فصل
بين يعني حركه الاخوان المسلمين كحركه
سياسيه وبين حركه الاخوان
المسلمين فصل عن
عن التزامهم بالامن الوطني في البلد الذي
يعملون فيه يعني فصل بين الامن والسياسه
فاذا نظرنا في بعض الدول التي
ذكرتيها في السعوديه وفي الامارات وفي مصر
بالدرجه الاولى حسب من شوفه هم اتجهوا الى
العنف واتجهوا الى الارهاب وهذا طبعا اذا
نظرنا الى الى الامن الوطني ليس هذا هو
الحال في البحرين ليس هذا هو الحال في
البحرين اذا كان افراد ليس الحال في
البحرين اذا كان اذا كان افراد الاخوان في
البحرين لم يرتكبوا نعم سيد جمشير اذا
كانوا في البحرين لمم لم يرتكبوا ما يضر
الدوله في البحر حين لما برايك استخدم لما
برايك استخدم الوزير عبارات من قبيل
التصدي لمخططات وانني لم اقل ان الجماعه
ليست ارهابيه وما الى
ذلك لا صحيح بس البحرين ملتزمه باتفاقيات
امنيه بينها وبين الدول الخليجيه والدول
العربيه فهي في هذا المجال تصد
لاي توجه ارهابي لدى حركه الاخوان الم
المسلمين ف يعني انا ارى ان ان ان هو كان
ركز على على على الحركه كحركه سياسيه تتبع
النهج السلمي وفي نفس الوقت النهج
الارشادي كدعوه
للدين ولاصلاح وهي بالفعل نسميه الاصلاح
سيد جش يعني يكاد يفهم ان الوزير في
تصريحاته يحاول ربما ان يوفق بين يعني في
العلاقه بين البحرين والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه وبين موقف البحرين من جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين التي كما قال لا تشهد لا
تشكل في الواقع خطرا على البحرين ولا تقوم
باي شيء ضد
الدوله لا لا حاول يفصل بين بين حركه
الاخوان كحركه
محليه وطنيه داخل البحرين
وبين
الحركه يعني مشروع الدولي او او او اللي
هي ارتباط
دوليا بالاخوان المسلمين في الخارج هذا هو
هو هذا لازم الخيط لازم يعني نتابعه
بطريقه واضحه
وبطريقه
يعني دقيقه على اساس نوصل الى الى الى الى
فت الارتباط بين الاخوان كحركه سياسيه
محليه تعمل في في الاصلاح وفي وفي السيا
وتعمل في في الاعمال الخيريه يعني وفي
الوع الديني وفي نفس الوقت بين الحركه
وارتباطه
بالمجموعه الدوليه
وتوجهات السياسيه وممكن ان ان ترتبط
بمخططات ارهابيه في الدول الاخرى وهذا ما
حصل ما يحصل في مصر يعني مصر
يعني نشوفها على ارض الواقع جميع الت رات
وجميع الحركات الارهابيه ناتجه عن عن عن
يعني خلفيه اخوانيه شكرا جزيلا لك اذا عبد
الرحمن جمشير عضو مجلس الشورى البحريني
كنت معنا من المنامه عبر الهاتف في هذا
الجزء الاول من البرنامج شكرا لحضورك معنا
واتحول الان الى الامارات والدكتور عبد
الخالق عبد الله دكتور عبد الحالق اهلا بك
استمعت الى الاستاذ عبد الرحمن جمشير وهو
يصف حركه الاخوه المسلمين في البحرين
بانها حركه اصلاحيه نريد ان نفهم في
الامارات العربيه المتحده
لماذا يعني يتخذ منها موقف استئصال مثل
الذي تتخذه الامارات من
الجماعه يعني الامارات
حقيقه لديها ادله وشواهد
ان
الاخوان حركه تلقين من اجل الوصول الى
السلطه و هدفها الاساسي السلطه والبقاء في
السلطه باي ثمن ان كان وثانيا اعتقد يعني
اكتشفنا بما لا يدع مجال للشك ايضا انه
حركه الاخوان بدات هجومها وتهاجمها
واستهدافها للامارات منذ اندلاع الربيع
العربي فكانت الامارات حقيقه يعني في حاله
رد فعل ليه هذا موقف من الربيع العربي
اكثر منه موقف من الجماع لا لا موقف من
الاخوان تحديدا وليس من الربيع العربي اخت
خديجه الاخوان بداوا هجوم مقدس هدوم كاسح
اعلامي سياسي بداها الشيخ الضاوي ومرورا
بكل من تولى السلطه في مصر اخذوا
موقف دون وجه حق ضد الامارات نعم دكتور
عبد الخالق لا اريد ان اقاطعك ولكن نريد
يعني هذا الكلام هذا نعم يعني في الواقع
يعني فعلا لا اريد ان اقاطعك لتواصل
الفكره لكن نريد فقط ان نسترسل في هذه في
سياق هذه الاتهامات المتواصل صله لجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين على انهم جماعه يريدون
كما تقول المساس والاطاحه بالحكم في دول
الخليج العربي تحديدا تتحدث عن الامارات
العربيه المتحده هل من شواهد هل من ادله
ال 60 ربما 60 شخصا المتهمون يتساءل المرء
هل يعقل ان يعني يسعى عشرات من الافراد
الى الاطاحه بحكم في دوله مثل الامارات
اولا يعني دوله الامارات كبقيه دول الخليج
ايضا معظمها على
الاقل لا تسمح
بقيام تنظيمات سياسيه القانون لا يسمح
والاخوان المسلمون في جماعه الاخوان في
دوله الامارات قاموا بانتهاك قون الامارات
وهم يدركون ذلت و بكامل وعيهم قاموا
بتجاوز القانون القضيه ضدهم قضيه قانونيه
بحته جماعه لم تلتزم بقوانين الامارات
وحكموا من منطلق انهم تنظيم سري لكن اكثر
من ذلك كلنا نعرف ان جماعه الاخوان منذ ما
تاسست ليست بجماعه دينيه وانما تستخدم
الدين للوصول الى السلطه وهذا الاستخدام
السيء الدين هو الذي يثير التحفز في
السعوديه تبقى معنا دكتور عبد الخالق فقط
لنوع الوقت بانصاف وبعدل على بقيه
الضيوف استاذ حمد الذب انتم متهمون بشكل
صريح في قطر بانكم تدعمون الاخوان قطر
تدعم الاخوان تحاول زعزعه الاستقرار في
دول الخليج وتحاول ايضا مد نفوذها
الاقليميه على حساب
جيرانها لا يوجد اي تنظيم للاخوان يعني
موجود في دوله قطر لكي تكون دوله قطر هي
داعمه الاخوان بالعكس اكبر تواجد الاخوان
هو موجود في الكويت وموجود في البحرين
ولذلك نجد ان وزير خارجيه البحرين اقر
بالامس بان جماعه الاخوان في البحرين هي
جماعه وطنيه وهذا حتى ايضا يتناقض مع
الادعاءات بان لديهم بيعتين بيعه داخليه
وبيعه خارجيه للمرشد في مصر او في غير مصر
دوله قطر نظامها ملكي مثلها مثل بقيه دول
الخليج مساله ان قطر يجب الا تحارب
الاخوان يجب الا تحول بان دوله قطر هي
داعمه للاخوان وموقف البحرين بالامس الذي
تم التراجع عنه اليوم بشكل غير مفهوم يدل
على ان هناك تباين في المواقف
واعتقد بان هناك يعني غطب كبير في ابو ظبي
بعد تصريحات الشيخ خالد بن احمد ال خليفه
وهي متوازنه لان البحرين ليست في حاجه الى
خلق صراعات داخليه
لارضاء يعني تصريحات ضاحي خلفان او غيره
من الامنيين الذين اصيبوا برعب بعد الربيع
العربي بل انهم ذهبوا الى ابعد من ذلك
عندما قالوا بان اول دوله سيتم اسقاطها هي
الكويت وكل الم حلين يعرفون بان جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين او من يحملون فكرهم في
الكويت هم شركاء لنظام الحكم هناك وهم
رجال اعمال وهناك مصالح مشتركه بينهم وبين
نظام الحكم في الكويت الذي يشبه الى حد
كبير جميع الانظمه في دول الخليج دوله قط
طيب طلما انك اشرت استاذ عبد الله الى
الكويت دعني انتقل الى الكويت
الى الاستاذ الدكتور عبيد الوسمي دكتور
عبيد نريد ان نفهم يعني ما ما المقلق ما
المخيف لماذا كل هذا القلق الراهن من
حكومات المنطقه في الخليج من جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين و صعود التيار الاسلامي
بعد الربيع
العربي انا اعتقد اجابه على هذا السؤال
انه ربما تكون اكثر الفصائل السياسيه
الاسلاميه تنظيمه وجماعه الاخوان المسلمين
ولذلك الخشيه من ان احداث الربيع الع
العربي وموجه التغيير في العالم العربي قد
تهيئ
للجماعات النظاميه اكثر يعني ولهذا السبب
البديل دائما اسلامي حتى قبل موجه الربيع
العربي الحاليه احنا شفنا في فتره سابقه
عندما يعني فاز جبهه الانقاذ في الجزائر
وايضا كان فصيلا اسلاميا في المناطق
المحتله في فلسطين كانت حماس بديلا وربما
لان التوجه الشارع وجهها محافظا وتوجها
اسلاميا وجماعه الاخوان المسلمين هي اقدر
الجماعات الاسلاميه المنظمه لملء فراغ
السلطه في حاله غيابها لكن الحديث ربما
الغير مفهوم للزميلين اللي سبقوني مع كامل
التقدير لما ذكره بشان المخططات يعني انا
لست هنا في معرض الدفاع عن الاخوه
المسلمين ولست منتميا لهذه الجماعه لكنني
استغرب ايضا من الحديث المكرر بان الاخوه
المسلمين لديهم مخططات للوصول الى السلطه
انا اود ان اقول ومن هذا المنبر ان كل
الفصائل السياسيه عندما تتنافس في الجانب
السياسي فان الهدف هو الحصول على القرار
والمشاركه به وبالتالي امر منطقي جدا ان
يكون الغرض من المشاركه السياسيه هو
التاثير على القرار السياسي اما بشكل
مباشر او شكل غير مباشر ولذلك هذا لا يعد
اتهاما لا للاخوان المسلمين ولا غيرهم من
الاشخاص يعني نحن نتنافس في الحاله
السياسيه لنعبر عن ارائنا ونترجم هذه
الافكار حاله الاخوان المسلمين ربما لانها
حركه كما قيل بانها عالميه الانتشار
وخصوصا في العالم العربي هي كذلك كما
غيرها من الحركات الماسونيه والصهيونيه
والراسماليه والشيوعيه كلها حركات فكريه
واسعه النطاق العالم العربي الطبيعه
المحافظه لمجتمعات العربيه دائما عندما
تاتي ببدائل من الشارع فان هذا البديل
دائما يكون اسلاميا
اكثر ربما في دول الخليج التركيبه
الاجتماعيه مختلفه نعم دكتور ربما في دول
الخليج التركيبه الاجتماعيه مختلفه مرجعيه
دولها ومجتمعاتها مرجعيه مرجعيتها هي
الاسلام والتشريع ومن ثم ربما يتساءل
البعض لماذا يعني الخوف من
انتماء افراد من هذه المجتمعات الى جماعه
اخوان المسلمين او اصلا سبب وجود هذه
الجماعه في مجتمعات اسلاميه بالاصل لكن
سنعود للنقاش بعد ان ناخذ فاصلا قصيرا
ونناقش بعد الفاصل كيف يمكن لدول الخليج
العربيه صياغه مواقف مشتركه ازاء اي تهديد
لامنها مع الحفاظ على مصالحها الوطنيه لا
تذهبوا بعيدا
[موسيقى]
عائدون نرحب بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الى هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش دلالات تصريح وزير
الخارجيه البحريني حول التعامل مع قضيه
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين في كل دوله على
حدا التحول الى الامارات الان والى
الدكتور عبد الخالق عبد الله دكتور عبد
الخالق يعني يتساءل البعض لماذا كل هذه
الشده في التعامل مع الاخوان المسلمين في
الامارات هل يحتلون مثلا جزرا في الامارات
العربيه المتحده لماذا لا تترك الامارات
كل دوله تتصرف وتتحرك بمفردها بناء على
مصالحها الوطنيه مع هذه
الجماعه يعني اولا اعتقد ان هناك تحفز
خليجي من الكويت ومر بالامارات والسعوديه
الى عمان تجاه الاخوان وتجاه التنظيمات
الاسلاميه التي تستقل الدين بشكل من
الاشكال للصول الى السلطه اعتقد هذا
التحفز قائم في جميع دول الخليج العربي
فيما عدا قطر التي خرجت عن هذا التحفز الى
طور المسانده والدعم المالي والمعني طبعا
الاعلامي عبر الجزيره ولكن الامارات ايضا
قاست اكثر من غيرها من الاخوان باست من
الاخوان بشكل خاص قبل ال العربي وخاصه فثر
الاونه الاخيره فيشكل هذا التطاول الذي
بداه يوسف القراوي ومرورا بتطاول الاخوان
في مصر عندما اتوا الى الحكم ثم اخيرا
ايضا عندما اكتشفنا ان هناك ايضا من ابناء
الامارات من كانوا يخططون وينسق مع
التنظيم الدولي فال التوجس الامار
الاماراتي قائم ومحق لان هناك مخالفات في
الداخل وهناك هجوم بعور اخوانيا ضد
الامارات بشكل خاص واستهداف للامارات ربما
اكثر من غيرها لكن ايضا فجاه السعوديه
اليوم اعلنت وبصريح العباره ان جماعه
الاخوان جماعه ارهابيه فهي ذهبت الى ابعد
مما ذهبت اليه الامارات وربما هنات خليج
القصد هنا ان الاخوان نرى انهم يعبثون
اليوم بمصر ويعبثون ب بوحدتها
وباستقراء الامه العربيه وبقيه دول الخليج
العربي والامارات طبعا من بين دول الخليج
تقدر عاليا انه هذا عدم الاستقرار اذاذا
اذا الذي يقوده الاخوان لانهم يريدون ان
يعودوا الى السلطه باي شكل من الاشكال ولو
كان ذلك على حساب انهيار الاقتصاد المصري
والبيت المصري على
راسين
ولكن لكن لكن في نفس الوقت الامارات دعمت
يعني الانقلاب في مصر و يعني عزل رئيس وصل
الى السلطه بطرق شرعيه عن طريق صناديق
الاقتراع هذه هي سياسه الامارات العربيه
المتحده في مصر قرت بحكم الاخوان وكانت من
بين اوائل الدول التي التي ساندت يعني
اعترفت بما اقر به وما ما عليه الشعب
المصري لكن خلال السنه اكتشفنا كم ان هذه
الجماعه التي اتت الى السلطه عبثت بمصر
وبعلاقات بدول دول الخليج وكانت مصر على
وشك ان تخ تخسر الامارات كما كانت
الامارات على وشك ان تخسر مصر عدتهم بمصر
خلال سنه الفكره واضحه فقط لانه لم يبقى
معنا الا الا ثلاث دقائق نحاول ان نوزعها
بين ضيفين دكتور عبيد الوسمي كيف يمكن
لدول الخليج الان ان ترسم سياسه
موحده يعني بالحفاظ على في نفس الوقت على
المصالح الوطنيه لكل دوله على حدا تحدث عن
الكويت لو
سمحت اولا بالنسبه للكويت انا اعتقد ان
الاخوان المسلمين هي جماعه تمارس العمل
السياسي وهي مكون سياسي من المكونات
الاساسيه في في المعادله السياسيه لم نسمع
يعني في يوم الايام ان الاخوان المسلمين
في الكويت كان لهم مخططات يعني لقلب نظام
الحكم او لتغيير نظام الحكم خصوصا ما يطرح
في في الساحه الخليجيه وان كنا نتمنى طبعا
ونحن نقف مع الاخوان في الامارات والبحرين
والمك السعوديه وغيرها من الدول اذا قدموا
مظاهر ماديه واضحه يعني على مثل هذه
المخططات او الاعمال الاجراميه الامر
الاخر ان اذا افترضنا جدلا ان مثل هذه
الامور تحدث فانه حتى من الناحيه الشرعيه
ولا تزر وزره وزره اخرى يعني تملك هذه
الانظمه ان تحاكم الاشخاص الذين يرتكبون
جرائم مخالفه لامن الدوله لكن لا يمكن ان
نسبغ هذه الصفه على كل كائنات الاخوان
المسلمين فقط لان هناك شخص او شخصين او
ثلاثه اذا افترضنا وجودهم منتمين لهذه
الجماعه وقاموا باعمال تخريبيه او اجراميه
لان عدد كبير اصلا من ال يعني من الجماعات
السياسيه في فترات من فترات التاريخ
السياسي في دول مجلس التعاون ارتكبوا
مجموعه من المخالفات ولم توصم هذه
الجماعات بانها جمع شكرا انتقل الى الى
الاستاذ عبد الله حمد العذبه الان كيف
يمكن لدول الخليج العربيه ان تصيغ يعني
مواقف مشتركه اذاء اي تهديد لامنها مع
الحفاظ على مصالحها
الوطنيه خروج البحرين بالتصريح هذا يعكس
بان لا يوجد هناك يعني موقف موحد من
التعامل مع ملف الاخوان كما ان عمان
والكويت يؤكدان يعني بان دوله قطر لا تشكل
اي تهديد المنطقه ولذلك لم تقوما بسحب
السفيرين من هنا على الرغم من ان الامارات
ليس لديها سفير لتسحب ولكنهم يصرون على
تكرار مساله انهم سحبوا سفير وهذا الامر
غير صحيح وارجو ان يكون هناك تفهم لموقف
البحرين فالبحرين لديها من المشاكل
الداخليه ما يكفيها ولا تشعر الكويت باي
شكل من الاشكال بان الاخوان يهددونه اما
مساله التعامل مع ملف مصر فيجب ان ينتقل
الى منظومه مجلس التعاون ويجب ان نحافظ
عليها وما يحدث في مصر يبقى في مصر وما
يحدث في سوريا يحدث في سوريا هناك وحده
مواقف هذه الانظمه السته هي انظمه ملكيه
وراثيه لن يضر اي نظام منها باي نظام اخر
وفي جميع الاحوال دوله قطر لا يستطيع احد
ان يحسبها على الاخوان المسلمين او غيرهم
وهذه امور مشاهده ودستورها حتى يحدد اليه
الحكم وانتقاله الى اخره دوله قطر من
مصلحتها استقرار مصر واستقرار المنطقه
كلها وهناك معالجه مختلفه انا اعتقد بان
يعني مصر تحتاج الى رئيس توافقي الى
العوده عن الانقلاب فاذا لم تستقر مصر
فيجب الا تلام دوله قطر على ذلك بزعم بان
دوله قطر تدعم الاخوان لان دوله قطر لا
تريد ان تكون تجاه اي طرف فهي دعمت المجلس
العسكري ثم دعمت حكومه شرف وغيره نعم
ودعمت الرئيس الذي اختاره الشعب المصري
ويجب الا تلام على ذلك شكرا جزيلا لك
استاذ عبد الله بن حمد الذبه مدير تحرير
صحيفه العرب القطريه ونشكر ايضا الدكتور
عبيد الوسمي استاذ القانون بجامعه الكويت
وعضو البرلمان السابق ونشكر ضيفنا من
الامارات الدكتور عبد الخالق عبد الله
استاذ العلوم السياسيه وفي الجزء الاول من
البرنامج كان معنا ايضا عبر الهاتف عبد
الرحمن جمشير عضو مجلس الشورى البحريني
كان معنا من المنامه بهذا بهذا ناتي
مشاهدينا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر لكم من اطيب المناى والى
اللقاء